this episode had it all a degrading and
defensive verbal attack on claire
i expected way more from the oldest
bachelorette
making out with dale more making out
with dale
making out with someone else just
kidding it was dale and a shocking
reveal of our possible next bachelorette
it's time for roses and rose
first off everybody let's check the dale
count from last night
oh dale dale dale dale dale dale claire
said his name
40 times everybody but jokes aside
claire did get in some
quality time with the other guys bubbles
yeah there's no way we're getting an
entire season of claire is there
especially because at the end we saw
tasha adams emerge from the pool
in slow motion if only there was someone
who could
provide us with some answers oh look
it's chris harrison
is this reveal of tasha confirmation
that she is our second bachelorette
um i think you can definitely start
leaning into the fact that things might
be
turning around soon look tasha was
always on the table to be
the back ciret she was always a fan
favorite she was always on the top of
our list
well i feel i have a very clear idea of
what's going on now because
last night claire called dale her fiance
you've dished on my fiance so hard
that did seem a little presumptuous
maybe
a little overly optimistic of things to
come i don't know
where is her head at this point i think
it was
sniffing dale's pants i don't know at
what point in a relationship you start
sniffing someone's
pants it seems early on uh
relationship to be at the stiff point so
claire ends up giving herself a rose
was that a franchise first yeah another
first
that wasn't a great look i just wanted
them to have a fair shot
and you could very very clearly see on
that date
they're not getting that shot anymore
claire has now called dale her fiance
she clearly wants to put a ring on it
could it be one of your rings
a great segue i'm partnering with manly
bands
you go to manlybands.com it's this
entire ring line
for men they really allowed me to create
this spectrum
where you can kind of find that ring
that speaks to you well
thank you for speaking with us chris
harrison can't wait for next week the
bachelorette is on a special night
[Music]
thursday